[Music]
recently I was on the Richard Quest show
on CNN TV and that was that's the
question that we have the Battle of the
billionaires on one hand we have Mark
Zuckerberg saying don't worry
artificial intelligence will give us new
jobs new industries create wealth
prosperity and then we have people like
well Elon Musk who says watch out they
pose an existential threat to humanity
who knows maybe one day they'll put us
in zoos and throw peanuts at us and make
us dance make us dance behind bars like
we do with monkeys and with bears well
my personal point of view is that both
points of view are in some sense correct
in the short term I think Zuckerberg is
right artificial intelligence will open
up whole new vistas it'll make life more
convenient things will be cheaper new
industries will be created I personally
think the AI industry will be bigger
than the automobile industry in fact I
think the automobile is going to become
a robot you'll talk to your car you'll
argue with your car your car will give
you the best facts the best Rob between
point A and point B the car will be part
of the robotics industry whole new
industries involving the repair
maintenance servicing of robots
not to mention robots that are software
programs that you talk to and make life
more convenient however let's not be
naive there is a point a tipping point
at which they could become dangerous and
pose an existential threat and that
tipping point is self-awareness you see
robots are not aware of the fact that
they're robots they're so stupid
they simply carry out what they are
instructed to do because they're adding
machines we forget that any machines
don't have a will adding machines simply
do when you program to do now of course
let's not be naive about this eventually
adding machines may be able to compute
alternate goals in alternate scenarios
when they realize that they aren't
human right now robots do not know that
however there is a tipping point at
which point they could become dangerous
now right now our most advanced robot
has the intelligence of a cockroach a
rather stupid cockroach however it's
only a matter of time before robots
become as smart as a mouse then as smart
as a rat then a rabbit then a cat dog
and eventually as smart as a monkey now
monkeys know they are not human they
have a certain amount of self-awareness
dogs especially young dogs are not quite
sure one reason why dogs obey the master
is because they think the master is the
top dog and so there will be confused
about whether or not we humans are part
of the dog tribe but monkeys I think
have no no problems with that they know
they're not human so when robots become
as intelligent as monkeys I think we
should put a chip in their brain that
shut them off if they begin to have
murderous thoughts when will that happen
I don't know I suspect it'll happen late
in this century because I think we have
decades of experience that have to be
that haven't we have to go through and
learn before we can pose this particular
problem so in other words I don't think
there's any rush today to deal with
killer robots that are gonna destroy the
human race and take over but I think we
have to keep one eye one eye in the ball
and realize that by the end of this
century when robots do become self-aware
we have to be careful
[Music]